La radio.
Donc juste pour vous rappeler du pourquoi on a lu ces passages,
Évore 11 à 10, c'est pour pointer déjà l'importance.
Nous sommes en train de plaider pour une interprétation littérale, historique des Jeunesses.
On est en train de discuter de la création, l'origine de toutes les choses
et la Bible nous présente de manière claire et inflexible
que toutes les choses ont été créées par la parole de Dieu,
comme l'auteur d'Hebreu est en train de pointer ici.
Et donc la manière dont Dieu a créé, c'était par sa parole,
de manière brève, de manière immédiate, sans matière préalable.
Et c'est intéressant de remarquer ici que l'interprétation de l'auteur biblique
et inspiré d'Hebreu, c'est littéral et historique.
Donc il va mentionner plusieurs personnages.
Donc quelques personnages qui deviennent très importants,
comme par exemple Adam, qui était le premier Adam,
et Christ qui appelait le deuxième Adam.
Donc l'interprétation littérale des Jeunesses a l'impact vis-à-vis un Christ,
comme notre représentant.
la question du jugement, la question de la chute,
donc c'est très important de me rappeler,
tout comme la mort et la première mort est entrée dans les mondes,
qui est par les péchés.
Donc il y a ces conflits avec la théorie symbolique des Jeunesses
qui veut s'accorder aux théories qui cherchent à dater les fossiles
comme en ayant des milliards ou des millions d'années.
Mais la réalité, c'est que pour nous, théologiquement,
c'est impossible que les mondes fossiles puissent exister,
que la mort puisse exister,
avant que l'homme ne soit créé
et avant que l'homme ne tombe dans les péchés, la chute.
Car la mort est rentrée dans les mondes à travers la chute du premier Adam.
Ici, nous voyons aussi cette liaison envers la cité céleste,
la cité future,
et il y a ces parallèles assez intéressants
entre l'historicité de cette terre originale parfaite
qui était l'Édant,
la terre promise qui était la représentation future,
et la liaison aussi historique avec la Jérusalem céleste.
Donc là, je vous pointe tout simplement
toutes les implications graves
qui ont à voir avec la conception même de salut,
qui ont à voir avec cette notion
des représentants légals devant Dieu,
donc les premiers Adam qui étaient les représentants légals
qui affectent la mort rentre,
et notre représentant légal qui est Christ,
le deuxième Adam.
Donc c'est l'historicité de deux
qui est la base pour cette représentativité qui nous sauve.
Donc même si on peut dire qu'une personne
qui ne peut pas avoir une interprétation littérale des jeunesses,
qui cherche à concilier la Bible
avec les théories évolutionnistes,
la terre vieille, etc.,
nous pouvons affirmer clairement
que personne ne sera sauvé
par sa position vis-à-vis à la création.
Nous sommes sauvés qui est par Christ
et par la foi en Christ.
Donc les personnes qui sont correctes
dans ce qu'ils disent,
ce n'est pas une question
qui peut compromettre les saluts de quelqu'un.
Par contre, les implications théologiques
sont tellement importantes
que nous ne pouvons pas négliger non plus
des personnes qui cherchent
à interpréter de manière non-biblique jeunesse.
Et donc pour nous,
la grande question c'est
à partir du moment
où je cherche à interpréter
de manière non-confessionnelle,
non-historique,
non-biblique,
Genèse chapitre 1,
non littérale tout simplement,
je suis en train de compromettre
plusieurs points doctrinaires
très importants pour les saluts
et surtout l'inspiration des Écritures,
l'autorité des Écritures
et la suffisance des Écritures
pour nous parler de ces choses.
Donc là, on est en train de considérer
tous les enjeux
lorsqu'on va s'enfuir
de cette interprétation littérale
qui a été toujours
la déclaration confessionnelle
de l'Église au nom de l'histoire,
toujours majoritaire
et qui respecte
les principes d'interprétation biblique
que nous trouvons
dans la Bible elle-même.
Qui peut nous enseigner
à interpréter la Bible ?
Ce n'est pas les hommes,
c'est la Bible elle-même.
Donc un exercice fondamental
d'Herménotique,
c'est de nous demander
comment les auteurs
intra-bibliques
ont toujours interprété
Genèse à titre 1.
Et ici, nous sommes devant
l'autorité de Brue par exemple
et on a vu plusieurs d'autres auteurs
comme Christ lui-même
et Dieu lui-même
lorsqu'il y a un exode,
il va dire qu'en six jours,
Dieu a créé toutes les choses,
les ciels et la terre
et toutes les choses
qu'elles contiennent.
Et donc, moi,
je ne peux pas interpréter
Genèse en désaccord
avec l'interprétation
des dieux lui-même
tel qu'est déclaré
dans la Bible.
Donc la question,
pour qu'on revienne
au point,
c'est lorsqu'on considère
la confession de foi,
on a déjà étudié
ce que la Bible enseigne
à propos d'elle-même,
l'inspiration,
l'autorité des écritures,
ensuite,
à propos des dieux,
qui est Dieu,
son être,
ses attributs,
et on est passé
à considérer
les œuvres des dieux.
On a commencé par
les décrets éternels des dieux,
Dieu a tout planifié
avant de créer,
et ensuite,
on a considéré
la création.
Quand on considère
la création,
les premiers êtres
créés sont les anges,
voilà pourquoi on étudie
à propos des anges
et aussi à propos
de la chute des anges.
Et ensuite,
on a commencé
à considérer
cet univers
que Dieu a créé.
La prochaine étape,
c'est de considérer
une portion particulière
et spéciale
de cette création
qui est l'être humain.
L'être humain
qui crée l'image des dieux,
ça mérite
une attention spéciale.
Ici,
c'est encore évoqué
quand on est en train
de considérer
la création
de tous les cosmos
et cela va comprendre
aussi l'être humain.
Mais après,
on va dédier
un peu plus de temps
à la considération
de l'homme lui-même.
L'origine
de l'univers,
de toutes les choses,
n'est pas
un sujet
exclusivement religieux.
C'est très important.
Au long de l'histoire,
on a toujours eu
de la part
de la philosophie,
des scientifiques,
un désir
à chercher
à comprendre
l'origine
de toutes les choses.
qu'est-ce qui pourrait
expliquer l'origine
de toutes les choses.
La première chose
qu'on a considérée,
c'est qu'une certitude
à propos
de l'origine
de l'univers
ne peut jamais
être atteignable
par la méthode scientifique.
Je vous ai expliqué,
la méthode scientifique,
elle est fondée
sur l'observation
et l'observation,
être un témoin
oculaire,
de quelque chose
qui est en train
de se répéter,
un phénomène
qui se répète.
et après avoir vu
des paramètres
qui vont se répéter
après plusieurs
et plusieurs
fois,
on va arriver
à ce qu'on appelle
les lois scientifiques.
Par observation,
par répétition,
nous pouvons arriver
à cette conclusion
et ce qu'on appelle
lois,
c'est presque
une pleine certitude,
mais même pas
que ces choses
vont continuer
et c'est répéter.
On est en train
de remarquer
des motifs
clairs,
évidents
et répétitifs
dans la création.
Et c'est ce qu'on appelle
science
ou c'est ce qu'on appelle
les lois scientifiques.
Donc pourquoi
l'origine de l'univers
n'est pas atteignable ?
Car il n'y avait pas
un individu,
un être humain
qui était
à l'origine
pour observer.
Tout ce qu'on peut
parler
quand on essaye
de découvrir
l'origine
de toutes les choses,
c'est à propos
des théories
et par l'observation
des lois présentes
dans l'univers,
on se demande
quel type d'origine
aurait pu engendrer
un tel monde.
Pour nous,
par exemple,
c'est logique
et même pas encore
religieux,
car c'est l'une
des possibilités
qui a été toujours
considérée,
c'est une origine
intelligente.
Avant qu'on parle
des religions,
c'est l'une
des théories
les plus
probables
déconsidérées
qu'un univers
qui présente
tellement d'intelligence,
un univers
qui présente,
par exemple,
des êtres
qui sont personnels,
il ne peut pas
être expliqué
par une origine
qui ne soit pas
personnelle.
Une énergie
qui ne pense pas,
qui n'a pas
des sentiments
n'aurait pas pu
engendrer
des êtres humains
qui sont personnels.
Et si nous voulons
être cohérents
avec la théorie
de l'évolution,
si notre origine
a été une origine
qui ne pense pas,
qui n'a pas
des sentiments,
des morales,
on essaie
de supprimer
la personnalité
de l'homme.
Et toutes ces choses
personnalités
doivent être supprimées.
Et c'est ça
qui va dicter
la direction
des philosophies
plus postmodernes,
irrationalistes
comme on dit.
Et donc là,
on a des bases
avant de parler
des religions,
on a trois théories
principales
qu'on a considérées.
C'est la théorie
de la génération
spontanée
et de la matière.
Au début,
rien.
Et à partir
des rien,
quelque chose
s'est autocréé.
Là,
on a vu
que c'est
la moins raisonnable
des toutes.
Car les rien,
quand on observe,
n'a pas la capacité
de créer
aucune chose.
Un deuxième,
c'est
la préexistence
éternelle
de la matière.
Ou même
que ce soit
tout simplement
ces éléments
originals chimiques
dans la théorie
de l'évolution
qui a provoqué
l'explosion.
Et la troisième,
c'est celle
qu'on considère
la plus irrénaible.
C'est une origine
intelligente
et personnelle
qui a pu donner
l'intelligence
à toutes les choses.
Et donc,
à partir du moment
où nous avons créé
des théories,
nous allons faire
de la science
pour chercher
à voir
les données
scientifiques.
Est-ce qu'ils sont
plus en train
de supporter
ces théories
ou celles-là ?
Est-ce qu'ils sont
plutôt contraires ?
Donc,
on sera
devant une théorie
possible,
on sera
plus
convaincu
ou moins convaincu
par les dons
scientifiques.
Sauf que
pour nous,
et là,
on va
considérer
notre position
privilégiée
en tant que chrétien,
nous avons
la foi
une fois
attestée,
confirmée,
car tout ce
qu'on a étudié
à propos
de la Bible
en tant qu'autorité,
en tant que parole
des dieux,
nous donne la certitude
que si jamais
l'être humain
peut connaître
quelque chose
avec certitude
à propos de la création,
à propos de lui-même,
il a besoin
que les créateurs
lui-mêmes
lui disent.
Car on n'a pas
la capacité
d'arriver
à des convictions
absolues,
d'être sûr
et certain
que nos interprétations
sont correctes
et exhaustives
à propos
des vérités
qu'on découvre
dans la vie.
Donc la Bible,
elle est là
car on avait besoin
que Dieu,
les créateurs
lui-mêmes,
nous parle.
Donc par la position
privilégiée,
à partir du moment
qu'on est en train
de croire
dans la parole
des dieux,
dans la Bible,
nous sommes devant
la seule personne
capable
d'être
un scientifique
quelque part
à l'égard
de la création.
Il était
le créateur,
il y était présent,
il a observé,
il a même
tout créé.
Et pour plus
que les langages
des dieux
lorsqu'ils nous donnent
les récits bibliques
à propos de la création
ne soient pas
un langage
qui a pour priorité
être un langage
scientifique,
ils croisent
avec des informations
scientifiques.
et la réalité
c'est qu'on n'a
jamais eu
aucune contradiction
entre la Bible
et la science.
Comme je vous ai dit,
on a eu des contradictions
entre des théories
qui sont prises
par loi
et des soi-disant
évidents scientifiques
qui sont plutôt
politisées,
manipulées,
mais qui ne peuvent
pas représenter
réellement
de la science.
Et de l'autre côté,
on a eu
des interprétations
bibliques erronées
qui sont arrivées
à des conclusions
erronées bibliques
à propos de la science,
de la création
et qui ont été
en contradiction
avec la nature.
L'univers
n'a qu'un auteur,
la Bible n'a qu'un auteur,
c'est les mêmes auteurs,
celui de la Bible
et celui du livre
de la nature
comme on l'appelle.
C'est Dieu lui-même.
Donc c'est impossible
de trouver aucune
contradiction
entre la Bible.
C'est vraiment
la parole des dieux
comme on les croit
enfermément.
Et s'il y a vraiment
les créateurs
de l'univers,
c'est impossible
d'avoir des vraies
contradictions
entre vraies sciences
et bonne interprétation
biblique.
On ferait mieux
de connaître
les faiblesses
scientifiques
liées à la théorie
de l'évolution.
Comme plusieurs scientifiques
les remarquent.
Et on ferait
encore mieux
de nous assurer
que l'enseignement
biblique est clair
et inflexible
à ces sujets.
Car ce qu'on a vu
et la catastrophe
pour les dernières
générations,
c'était une église
mal informée
par rapport
aux fallaces
de la théorie
de l'évolution
sous la pression
de la popularisation
de cette proposition
qui est devenue
conventionnelle
qu'on nous enseigne
depuis l'enfance
à l'école.
Et sous cette pression,
certains théologiens
ont subi la pression
et ont cherché
à adapter
une interprétation
biblique
à ces choses.
En s'enfouillant
des principes,
en sacrifiant
les principes
bibliques
d'interprétation
et en s'enfouillant
et en se déconnectant
de l'histoire
de l'interprétation
biblique.
Voilà pourquoi
la première
grande leçon
pour nous
c'était
de nous plonger
de manière
indubitable
que l'interprétation
littérale
des Jeunesses
a toujours été
une question
confessionnelle.
Ça a toujours été
la déclaration
d'interprétation
biblique historique
au long de l'histoire.
Là,
on a trouvé
au long de l'histoire
une église
solide,
confessionnelle,
connectée
à l'interprétation
historique chrétienne.
On a trouvé
majoritairement,
prédominamment,
une église
qui interprétait
Jeunesse
comme littérale.
Et ça
devrait être
les cas pour nous
aujourd'hui.
Les plus
importants pour nous,
surtout devant
les enjeux
et les implications
que je vous ai
présentées,
mettre en question
les principes
d'interprétation
biblique,
mettre en question
la Bible
elle-même,
avoir des implications
pour la représentativité
légale du Christ
et même
les jugements.
Ce sont des enjeux
qui nous montrent
de manière très claire
que la plus grande
bataille,
elle est jouée
sur l'interprétation
de la Bible.
Car je vous ai proposé
que dans les prochaines
leçons,
je vais vous présenter
de manière un peu plus
apologétique
comment la science
et les dernières
découvertes réelles
et la science
sont plutôt en train
de jouer
pour confirmer
l'interprétation
littérale biblique.
Mais pour nous,
les plus importants
n'est même pas
de nous fier
aux arguments scientifiques.
Pour nous,
les plus importants,
c'est la Bible
et la parole de Dieu,
c'est est-ce que nous sommes
en train d'interpréter
la Bible
avec les critères bibliques.
Et donc,
ce qu'on a appris
à partir
des principes
d'interprétation
biblique
à propos des Jeunesses,
on a considéré
quelques vérités
plus importantes
pour nous
et plus claires.
Donc,
la première chose
qu'on a considérée,
c'était
quel est le but
de la création.
La Bible nous enseigne
que Dieu a créé
toutes les choses
exactement de la manière
dont la Bible dit
qu'il a créé
afin de maximiser
la révélation
de sa gloire.
Donc,
c'est pour sa gloire
que Dieu a créé
toutes les choses.
Je vous encourage
à écouter
les messages derniers
pour considérer
de manière plus profonde
et plus belle
ce qui s'est là
en termes d'implication.
Il n'y avait pas
un besoin en Dieu
pour créer
quoi que ce soit.
il n'était pas
en nécessité
de quoi que ce soit,
mais il a débordé
en bonté
et il a créé
les choses
pour sa gloire
et il prend plaisir
dans les choses
qu'il a créées.
Donc,
voilà,
si nous sommes compris
dans cette création,
c'est la plus grande
bénédiction de l'être humain
d'avoir été créé
avec la capacité
de déchiffrer
la gloire de Dieu
dans la création
et répondre
en adoration
en débordement
de satisfaction
en contemplant
la manière
dont Dieu
a créé les choses.
Et donc,
les points à renforcer,
c'est exactement
la manière
dont la Bible nous dit
que Dieu a créé
les choses.
C'est la manière
qui maximise
plus la révélation
de la gloire de Dieu.
Donc,
qu'est-ce qui rend plus
les gloires à Dieu ?
Que Dieu ait créé les choses
de manière que les choses
elles-mêmes doivent prendre
des générations et générations
pour se développer
où la toute-puissance
des dieux
s'affiche davantage
par le fait
que Dieu a créé
toutes les choses
rapidement.
C'est juste
une des questions
qu'on doit se poser
mais on voit aussi
toute l'ordre
qui est présenté
et même une interdépendance
de toutes ces choses.
Donc,
pourquoi,
lorsque Christ a ressuscité
Lazare,
il n'a pas eu besoin
de dire aux personnes
« Donc, attendez,
j'ai déclenché
la résurrection de Lazare,
attendons quelques ères
et générations
jusqu'à ce que
il puisse réévoluer
et devenir un grand être humain. »
Donc,
pourquoi,
devant les miracles
historiques immédiats,
on n'a pas de problème
de voir un Dieu
qui a la capacité
de les faire
et devant cette réalité
de l'univers,
on n'est pas
parfois conscient
du besoin
qu'une théorie
avec six temps
d'échecs,
une théorie
avec six temps
des manquements
a besoin
d'un âge
très vieil
de la Terre
pour nous donner
la moindre probabilité
comme si on pourrait croire
qu'un camion
qui vient d'être
renversé,
un camion
de supermarché
a pu créer
un gâteau.
Et c'est difficile
pour nous décroire,
mais si on vous dit
« Mais si des milliards
et des milliards
de camions
se tournent,
vous ne pouvez pas croire
qu'un jour
un gâteau sera fait. »
Voilà la nécessité
de manière très,
bien sûr,
simplifiée,
mais je vous encourage
à revenir en arrière.
Donc la deuxième vérité
qu'on a considérée,
les buts,
c'est pour la gloire
de Dieu.
La deuxième vérité,
c'est l'auteur,
donc qui a créé
toutes les choses,
c'est Dieu lui-même
et les dieux trinitaires.
Les pères,
les fils
et les Saint-Esprits
sont engagés.
Donc on a aussi considéré
les versets
qui concernent.
La troisième vérité,
c'est celle
qu'on a pris
le temps,
la dernière leçon
pour nous plonger
le plus,
pour la considérer.
Donc c'est la question
de la durée des jours.
Donc comment Dieu
a créé toutes les choses
et la première question
sous les « comment »
c'est quand
ou dans quelle
durée des temps.
Donc la Bible nous dit
au commencement,
Dieu a créé
toutes les choses,
donc toutes les choses
ont été créées
au commencement.
et toutes les choses
ont été créées
au commencement
de manière courte
et brève,
rapide.
Pour être très clair,
on va relire
la confession de foi.
Premier paragraphe,
au commencement,
il a plu à Dieu
Père,
Fils et Saint-Esprit
pour la manifestation
de sa gloire
et de son éternelle puissance,
de sa sagesse
et de sa bonté
décréer
ou défaire
en six jours
les mondes
et tous ces
qui se trouvent,
choses visibles
et invisibles
et tout était
très bon.
Donc ce qu'on a considéré,
c'est qu'il y a
aujourd'hui
quatre propositions
d'interprétation
dont une seule
est reconnue
comme majoritaire
au long de toute l'histoire,
c'est celle
qu'on vous présente
l'interprétation littérale.
L'autre,
les autres sont
considérés un jour
comme une période longue,
considérés
une interprétation
tout simplement
complètement allégorique,
donc Dieu n'était pas
intéressé
à nous présenter
quelque chose
de littéral,
c'est plutôt
des laissances
spirituelles
plus allégoriques
et d'autres,
c'est les cadres
fonctionnels.
Donc l'ordre là,
on peut voir clairement
comment même
la science
ou même la théorie
d'évolution
peut identifier
quelques connexions
mais c'est plutôt
un cadre fonctionnel
mais pas forcément
la vérité littérale.
Donc pour nous,
toutes ces interprétations
ne sont pas
légitimes
à partir
des principes
bibliques
et nous avons
considéré
huit arguments
des principes
d'interprétation
bibliques
qui nous empêchent
d'interpréter
d'aucune autre manière
ces textes
sans qu'ils soient
littéraux.
Donc on n'aurait pas
l'état aujourd'hui
de revenir sur
mais il y a
la cohérence
directe du texte,
la signification
des mots,
la définition
des soirées matins,
les mêmes termes
pour les trois
derniers jours
qui sont marqués
par les soleils
sont les mêmes termes
qui sont utilisés
pour les trois
premiers jours.
Il y a la cohérence
fonctionnelle,
logique et biologique
donc si on pense
que les trois
premiers jours
étaient des airs,
si on pense
à des airs
des ténèbres,
toute la création
qui avait été créée
serait complètement
détruite
car elle ne peut pas
se tenir en vie
après toutes ces airs
des ténèbres.
Donc il y a
la cohérence
théologique,
donc il y a
ces mouvements
vers l'apothéose,
vers la création
de l'être humain.
L'essence
de tous les univers
c'était que l'homme
vienne couronner
la création,
donc il n'y a aucun sens
d'avoir beaucoup,
des milliards et des milliards
d'années entre la création
de toutes les choses
et l'homme.
Il y a la cohérence
non seulement
théologique
mais aussi la cohérence
interne des écritures.
Genèse a plein d'évidence
d'être un livre historique.
Les auteurs
et les autorités bibliques
les prennent par historique
et là
Dieu lui-même
en exode de vent,
Christ lui-même
dans plusieurs passages
et tous les auteurs
du Nouveau Testament
et l'histoire
de l'Église.
Donc là
on a vu tout ça
la dernière fois
et aujourd'hui
on va voir
l'autre partie
du comment.
La première partie du comment
c'était plutôt
la durée des jours.
La deuxième partie du comment
c'est
par rapport à la manière.
De quelle manière
Dieu a créé toutes les choses.
Et là
c'est tout simplement
de nous plonger
dans les textes de Genèse
et de percevoir
comment la sagesse,
la puissance des dieux,
la bonté des dieux
sont maximisées
dans la création
de la manière littérale
dont la Bible nous présente.
Et donc
de quelle manière
Dieu a fait
pour maximiser
la révélation
de sa gloire.
Dieu a créé
toutes les choses
de sa propre puissance
sans existence
des matières préalables
de manière planifiée,
ordonnée
et parfaitement fonctionnelle
et compréhensible
particulièrement pour l'homme.
Donc nous allons
nous plonger
sur ces aspects
et c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
dans les textes bibliques.
Donc comme j'ai été
en train de poser
la question à certains
avant la lecture
et la prière,
c'est déjà très intéressant
de remarquer
dans la Bible
qui est l'intentionnalité
de Dieu
de révéler
ce qu'il nous a révélés,
c'est pour maximiser
notre capacité
de contempler sa gloire.
Et Dieu se montre
comment Dieu
qui va
de manière progressive
révéler
des choses glorieuses
à nous
et ce qui a été révélé
de manière explicite
même si pas exhaustive
par rapport
à la création
avait non seulement
un but immédiat
pour révéler sa gloire
pour qu'on puisse
l'adorer
à travers la création
mais c'était déjà
une manière des dieux
de préparer les terrains
pour établir
nos fonctions
tant qu'être humain
dans cet univers
pour les glorifier
et aussi préparer les terrains
par rapport
aux futurs glorieux
qu'il avait révélé,
réservés pour nous.
Et donc il y a
ce qu'on appelle
dans la Bible
révélation progressive
envers les plans
de rédemption
et les buts ultimes
de tous les êtres humains.
Donc juste pour
anticiper un peu
les choses,
quand on pense
que l'homme
a été créé
à l'image des dieux,
on se demande
parfois
si Christ
a été une nouvelle idée,
les Christ incarnés
dans la pensée des dieux,
provoqués
par la nécessité
de notre chute
ou si nous avons
déjà été créés
à l'image des dieux,
fondé notre image
sur les Christ incarnés,
ressuscités, glorifiés,
qui est la base finale
de notre glorification
et notre connexion à Dieu.
Donc par exemple,
lorsque Paul va décrire
homme créé,
homme et femme,
est-ce que Christ
et l'illustration
de la relation
entre Christ
et l'Église
est une illustration
à postériori
de la réalité humaine ?
Donc Dieu a créé
homme et femme
dans un cadre marital
et après il s'est dit
voilà une bonne illustration,
peut-être que je vais pouvoir
utiliser cette illustration
pour parler de l'Église
et du Christ.
C'est le contraire.
Paul dit
c'est mystère et glorieux.
Lorsqu'il a créé
l'homme et la femme
dans un cadre marital,
c'était déjà
à l'image
de la relation
qui est venue d'abord
dans la pensée de Dieu,
la relation entre Christ
et l'Église.
Et donc c'est très intéressant
de voir la gloire
de ces réflexions
car Dieu n'est pas en train
de développer
des plans B dans l'histoire.
Ses décrets éternels
ont tout planifié
de manière glorieuse
dès le départ.
Avant la fondation du monde,
il nous a élus en Christ,
son Église.
Et donc c'est intéressant
de remarquer
quand on regarde
les deux premiers chapitres
de la Bible,
on va lire
verset 1 à 4
de Genèse.
Au commencement,
Dieu créa les cieux
et la terre.
La terre était en forme vide,
il y avait des ténèbres
à la surface de l'abîme
et l'esprit de Dieu
s'est mouvert
au-dessus des eaux.
Dieu dit
que la lumière soit
et la lumière fut.
Dieu vit que la lumière
était bonne
et Dieu sépara
la lumière
d'avec les ténèbres.
Dieu appela
la lumière jour
et il appela
les ténèbres nuit.
En silue,
en soir,
il y a eu un matin,
ce fut les premiers jours.
Au commencement,
Dieu créa les cieux
et la terre.
Quand on va vers
le chapitre 21
d'Apocalypse,
le 20 dernier chapitre,
c'est qu'on va le trouver.
« Puis j'ai vu un nouveau ciel
et une nouvelle terre.
Car les premiers ciels
et la première terre
avaient disparu
et la mer n'était plus.
Et j'ai vu des centres du ciel
de près des dieux,
la ville sainte,
la nouvelle Jérusalem,
préparée comme une épouse
qui s'est parée
pour son époux. »
Donc, chapitre 1,
ciel et terre.
Chapitre 21,
nouveau ciel,
nouvelle terre.
Si on va vers
le chapitre 2
des Jeunesses,
au verset 9,
on va lire.
« L'éternel Dieu
fit pousser du sol
des arbres
de toutes espèces
agréables à voir
et bons à manger
et l'arbre de la vie
au milieu du jardin. »
C'est un arbre
possiblement métaphorique ?
Pas du tout.
« Et l'arbre
de la connaissance
du bien et du mal.
En feu,
le sortait des dents
pour arroser les jardins
et dès là,
il se divisait
en quatre bras. »
Le nom du premier
est « Pichon ».
C'est celui
qui entoure
les pays d'Avila.
Vous voyez
l'historicité,
la géographie,
la préoccupation
littérale,
historique
de Moïse
de décrir
exactement
où
Éden
pourrait être trouvé
car ces feuves,
ces arbres,
ces arbres
étaient littérales
et là,
on peut identifier
par ces rivières
qui existaient encore,
qui étaient encore
nombées de cette manière,
ils pouvaient être
identifiés.
Où se trouve l'or ?
L'or de ces pays
est pur.
On y trouve
aussi
les Bélions
et la Pyrdonix.
Les noms
du second feuble
« Guiron »
c'est celui-ci
qui entoure
les pays
des Couches.
Les noms
du troisième
« Idékel »
c'est celui
qui coule
à l'orient
de la Syrie
et le quatrième
fleuve
c'est l'Euphrate,
l'Éternel
prit l'homme
et les plaça
dans les jardins
des dents
pour les cultiver
et les garder.
Donc la préoccupation
historique de Genèse,
qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve
en chapitre 2 ?
Donc,
on a considéré
les fleuves
mais on a considéré
particulièrement
l'arbre de la vie.
C'est l'attente
primaire et principale
de l'être humain.
C'est de rendre
sa condition éternelle
l'arbre de la vie.
Dieu, par grâce,
nous a privés
après la chute
de manger de cet arbre
pour ne pas rendre
notre condition
pécheresse éternelle
et Dieu a développé
dans l'histoire
notre plan de rédemption
afin que nous
puissions retourner
et manger définitivement
de cet arbre
dans les paradis.
Donc,
qu'est-ce qu'on va trouver
en Apocalypse 22 ?
Et il me montra
un fleuve
d'eau
de la vie,
limpide
comme du cristal
qui sortait
de tronc des dieux
et de l'agneau.
Au milieu
de la place
de la ville
et sur deux bords
du feu,
il y avait
un arbre de vie
produisant douze fois
des fruits
rendant son fruit
chaque mois
et dont les feuilles
servaient à la guérison
des nations.
Donc,
si vous voulez
éviter
de considérer
la réalité
des Jeunesse
comme une réalité littérale,
il faut aussi
mettre en question
la réalité
de notre certitude
et de la Jérusalem
céleste
que Dieu
a préparée pour nous.
Et donc là,
c'est juste pour vous
donner un exemple
de comment Dieu
a créé
toutes les choses
de manière
à maximiser
sa gloire.
Car toute l'histoire
est gouvernée
de manière
à maximiser
sa gloire
et la création
est aussi
cette constante
qui est en train
de manifester
la gloire
des dieux
depuis les jours
où Dieu
les a fixées.
Donc,
comment Dieu
a créé
toutes les choses ?
On va
remarquer
certains aspects
de cette création.
Donc,
le premier aspect
qu'on va considérer,
c'est
que Dieu
a créé
toutes les choses
de manière
séparée
ou distincte
de lui-même
et toutefois
complètement
dépendante
de lui-même.
C'est très important.
C'est une décision
de la part de Dieu
de créer
de manière libre.
Donc là,
la confession,
elle nous dit,
il n'a plus
Dieu
de créer.
Quand on va
prendre une définition
de la création,
on va dire
que la création
est l'acte
souverain
des dieux.
Un acte
souverain
par lequel
il produit
à partir
des riens.
Donc,
c'est une création
qui n'aurait pas
pu justifier
une corruption
qui soit
inhérente
à elle-même.
On ne peut pas
chercher
à trouver
chez la création
elle-même
une corruption
qui aurait pu
entraîner
cette corruption
de l'humanité,
par exemple.
C'est intéressant
car si tout
a été créé
à partir
des riens
par Dieu,
si l'origine
ultime
est Dieu,
nous ne pouvons
pas penser
à une possibilité
ou possibilité
d'une nécessité
d'évolution
ou d'amélioration.
Si tout vient
de Dieu,
tout doit venir
pur,
parfait.
Et donc,
la réalité,
c'est que
comme Dieu
n'a pas créé
les choses
à partir
de quelque chose
qui aurait pu
avoir une espèce
des contaminations
ou qui pourrait
manquer
des perfections,
des fonctionnalités,
si Dieu est
à l'origine,
c'est Dieu
lui-même
qui porte
quelque chose
qui est séparé
de lui-même
mais qui vient
et qui vient
à partir
de rien.
Donc,
Dieu a créé
quelque chose
qui dépend
complètement
de lui.
Donc,
ce n'est pas
un horlogier
qui a créé
toutes les choses,
qui a fait
les cordes
et qui a disparu.
C'est un univers
qui ne peut
qui continuer
d'exister,
de vivre,
de bouger,
d'avoir cette énergie
car il est
connecté
à cette prise
qui est la présence
de Dieu,
un Dieu
qui permet
toutes les choses
mais qui ne peut
souffrir
d'aucune manière,
aucun impact
à partir de la matière.
Donc,
tout dépend
de Dieu
et c'est un Dieu
qui donc,
car c'est lui
qui soutient
toutes les choses
dépendent de lui
pour exister
et pour continuer
en existence,
c'est un Dieu
qui a la liberté
d'agir
à travers les lois
qu'il lui-même
a créées
mais qu'il a aussi
la liberté
d'agir
malgré
de sousprendre
les lois.
C'est ce qu'on appelle
les miracles.
Donc là,
on est devant
l'univers
qui a été créé
séparé des dieux,
distant des dieux.
Donc,
au commencement,
Dieu créa
toutes les choses.
Prochaine chose
qu'on doit dire,
c'est que
toutes les choses
que Dieu a créées
ont suivi
une structure
très intelligente.
Nous allons
contempler
des évidences
des plannings,
de l'ordre,
fonction,
interaction,
interdépendance
et même
une espèce
d'évaluation
déclarée par Dieu
qui confirme
la perfection
de sa fonctionnalité
et la bonté
des choses
que Dieu a créées.
Donc,
à partir du moment
où Dieu lui-même
met son certificat
et tout était bon,
c'est pour qu'on n'ait
aucun doute
que tout était
en parfait fonctionnement
lorsque Dieu a créé.
Il n'y avait même pas
besoin
d'ématurer
quelque part.
Même les arbres
que Dieu a fait pousser,
il les a fait pousser,
selon les textes,
nous dit,
déjà avec ses fruits.
Et bien sûr
que les lois
pour les multiplications,
les lois
pour les reproductions,
les lois qu'on appelle
les lois de la providence,
y étaient déjà
pour les maintiens,
pour la continuité.
et ces choses-là
allaient maturer,
mais la réalité,
c'est que
Dieu lui-même
a porté
à la fin
de ces six jours
la maturité
des premiers êtres.
Et donc,
il y a
structure,
planning,
ordre,
fonction,
interaction
et une évaluation
de la part
de Dieu lui-même
qui va certifier
ces choses.
Et donc,
nous allons donc
considérer
ces éléments.
Donc,
les premiers aspects,
lorsqu'on dit
que Dieu a créé
toutes les choses
séparées de lui-même,
c'est important
car la Bible,
elle est très claire
pour nous présenter
quelques mots
qui sont importants.
Dans la première leçon,
la toute première leçon
introductoire,
tu sais que je vous ai
déjà présenté
un petit peu
ces choses,
mais là,
ça devient plus important
pour nous car
on est en train
de considérer
ces aspects
de la création,
la manière
de la création
pour maximiser
la contemplation
ou la révélation
de la gloire
de Dieu
et de la puissance
de Dieu.
Donc,
il y a quelques termes
qui sont importants.
Celui qui est
très important
pour nous,
c'est Amar
en termes hébraïques
qui signifie
un décret créateur
prononcé.
Donc,
lorsqu'il nous,
l'histoire du christianisme
conservateur
a toujours défini
la création
comme une création
fiat,
car fiat,
c'est la traduction
latine
pour ces mots
Amar.
Et les mots
Amar
signifient
une déclaration
irrésistible,
autoritative
de la part
de Dieu.
Et donc,
ces termes
vont apparaître
lorsque
la Bible
en Genèse 1-3
va dire
« Et Dieu dit
que la lumière soit
et la lumière fut. »
Et dans d'autres passages,
lorsque la Bible
nous dit
que c'était
par la parole,
par les fils
que toutes les choses
ont été créées,
et lorsque la Bible
en hébreu
comme on a lu aussi,
nous dit
que par la foi,
nous croyons
que toutes les choses
ont été créées
par la parole
de Dieu.
Et donc,
c'est très intéressant
quelle est
la médiation,
si on peut dire
comme ça,
à travers laquelle
Dieu apporte
toutes les choses
hors des rions.
C'est à partir
du moment
où Dieu déclare.
C'est Dieu a déclaré
que la lumière soit
et la lumière fut.
Et vous voyez déjà
combien ça maximise
la puissance
des Jeux.
Combien ça maximise
la révélation
de la gloire des Jeux,
que toutes les choses
aient été créées
par la parole
des Jeux.
Cette parole,
on comprend très bien
plus tard,
c'est la médiation
du Fils
dans la puissance
du Saint-Esprit,
mais la déclaration
des Jeux
est celle
qui engendre
toutes les choses.
Donc,
si l'effort
des Jeux
pour créer
quelque chose,
c'est un effort
comparé
à tout simplement
parler,
d'où viennent
les besoins
que toutes les choses
prennent du temps
pour se développer.
Vous comprenez ?
Ce qui maximise,
c'est Fiat.
En plus,
les termes
Barra,
donc là,
on a tout simplement
la maximisation
non seulement
de la gloire
des Jeux
lorsqu'il dit
tout simplement
et toutes les choses
sont,
mais aussi,
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que c'est un acte
souverain.
C'est Dieu
qui a décidé,
il n'a plus de Dieu,
il l'a fait
de la manière
qu'il a voulu
et heureusement
étant fait par Dieu,
ça sera toujours
parfait,
saint et bon.
L'autre terme
important
en Genèse 1,
c'est la création
qu'on appelle
ex nihilu,
c'est-à-dire
à partir des liens,
sans l'usage
des matériels
préalables
et c'est Barra.
Donc,
ces verbes,
il est utilisé
pour désigner
une création
à partir des liens.
Dieu n'avait pas
besoin
d'une matière
préexistante
pour créer les choses.
Donc,
Barra
est les termes
qui vont apparaître
par exemple
en Genèse 1,
1,
au commencement,
Dieu créa
les cieux
et la terre.
Donc,
c'est pour définir
que l'ensemble
des choses
qui composent
notre univers
ont été créées
par la parole
des dieux.
Et donc là,
c'est une description
de l'ensemble,
mais lorsque la Bible
va nous donner
le développement
de cette création,
il y aura
certains éléments
que Dieu va créer
à partir des liens
et d'autres éléments
qui seront plutôt
modelés
à partir
d'une matière primaire
que Dieu a déjà créée.
Donc,
asa,
c'est un autre terme
qu'on va trouver
qui signifie
faire,
accomplir
ou organiser,
faire produire.
Donc là,
il y avait déjà
un matériel,
des bases
et quelque chose
est développé
au-dessus
de ces choses.
En autre terme,
et donc là,
ça a plutôt
une connotation
à nouveau
d'intelligence,
d'organisation,
d'accomplissement
et voilà pourquoi
la Bible nous dit
de manière très claire
au commencement,
Dieu créa
les ciels,
la terre,
la terre était
en forme en vide
et à partir de là,
Dieu commence
à façonner,
à modeler,
à faire produire
dans une période
de six jours.
Et donc là,
on voit
un autre terme
qui est
Yatsar
et celui-là,
il a plus encore
l'essence
de façonner,
de modeler,
de former.
Donc,
lorsqu'il y a
la Bible dit
l'éternel Dieu
forma l'homme
de la poussière
du sol,
c'est très important,
surtout lorsqu'on va
faire les dialogues
avec la science,
de ne jamais dire
que Dieu a fait
l'être humain
de la boue.
c'est de la poussière
et l'éternel,
c'est tellement technique
que dans
la septuagente,
la septante,
la version latine,
la traduction,
ça sera
la moindre
particule connaissable.
Dieu n'a pas fait
à partir
tout simplement
de sable,
mais des atomes
qui sont trouvés
dans les sables.
Et c'est très intéressant
car lorsqu'il nous
allons vers
la composition
physiologique,
chimique
de l'être humain,
nous allons retrouver
les composants
qu'il faut
sur la poussière
de la terre,
les atomes
de la terre.
C'est très intéressant
car Dieu,
il a pris
cette matière primaire
et vient sur
l'homme n'est pas
complet avant
les souffles
du Saint-Esprit,
mais c'est intéressant
car quand on va
vers toutes les nouvelles
découvertes scientifiques
et la composition
de la poussière
de toutes les autres
planètes qu'on a déjà
connues,
et même de l'une
de ces planètes,
on n'a jamais trouvé
ce qu'il faut
pour identifier
la composition
d'un être mort.
Et donc,
la poussière,
Dieu a façonné
l'être mort.
Donc,
par là,
on va de manière
très claire
qui est Dieu
à créer
toutes les choses
à partir
de rien,
c'est la création
qu'on appelle
fiat,
la déclaration
des dieux
pour créer
toutes les choses.
Un autre aspect,
c'est donc
de manière
encore plus évidente
cet ordre
et cette planification,
cette intégration.
Donc,
bien sûr qu'il y a
plein de leçons
qui doivent rester
pour nous
car Dieu
veut
que nous travaillons,
que nous vivons
notre vie
à son image.
Pourquoi Dieu
est-ce en train
de révéler
la clarté
de ces choses ?
Non seulement
pour que de manière
contemplative,
on l'adore,
mais que de manière
imitative,
on reproduise sa vie,
sa manière de vivre,
de travailler,
de créer,
d'ordonner des choses.
La première chose
remarquable,
c'est d'identifier
dans l'ordre
de la création
telle qu'elle est
révélée par la vie,
par Genèse,
comment on est en train
de suivre
les fondamentaux
avant d'arriver
à la vie.
Si d'un côté
de l'être humain,
il est la couronne
de la création,
il ne peut pas être
maintenu
ni exister
sans les compositions
plus fondamentales
qui Dieu est en train
d'établir dans l'univers.
Quelque part,
avant de considérer
même la création
de l'homme
à son image,
on devrait considérer,
comme l'a fait
Lloyd-Jones
dans sa systématique,
la providence.
car toutes les lois
du maintien
de la planète,
toutes les lois
qu'on va découvrir
par la science,
ont été créées
aussi par Dieu
pour que tout
cet univers
soit parfaitement
intégré
afin que toutes
les vies
qui seront
mises
puissent
continuer
leur existence.
et donc
les plus fondamentaux
et les plus
nécessaires
avant,
donc la lumière.
Ensuite,
les eaux,
la séparation
des eaux,
donc on voit
comment il y a
un ordre
très intéressant,
des choses
plus fondamentales
qui sont
nécessaires
dans cet univers.
Ensuite,
on voit aussi
comment les
environnements
sont faits
avant
que la vie
soit présente
et que
la composition
de ces êtres
sont prises
aussi
de leur
environnement.
Donc,
les eaux
produisent
ces animaux.
De la poussière
de la terre,
l'être humain.
Et voilà
pourquoi il y a
une interaction
très importante
et plusieurs
données
scientifiques
qui vont chercher
plutôt à suggérer
par là
une espèce
d'évolution
car les êtres
plus complexes
seront retrouvées
sur Terre.
Nous voyons
et nous comprenons
comment on a
des points
communs
avec toutes
les espèces
car on a été créés
tous pour habiter
les mêmes univers
composés par les mêmes
éléments chimiques
par exemple.
Et donc,
le fait que notre embryon
puisse être similaire
à l'embryon d'un reptile
par exemple
n'est pas un indice
pour suggérer
que nous sommes
des sources communes.
C'est tout simplement
nous avons été créés
pour habiter
dans les mêmes univers.
Dieu a créé
certains êtres
avec plus de complexité
que d'autres
et rien n'empêche
Dieu avec son intelligence
de faire osage
des mêmes systèmes
et qui lui-même
a plus développé
ou des systèmes
similaires
qui lui-même
a plus développé
comme les systèmes
digestifs,
etc.
ou réproductifs
qui peuvent être
qui peuvent avoir
des antecessions.
La simple explication
c'est les mêmes créateurs
pour habiter
les mêmes univers
ou la même planète.
Mais plus que ça,
non seulement la Bible
elle dit clairement
qu'il nous donne
de l'ordre,
de la planification,
de l'intégration,
mais c'est intéressant
de voir ces parallèles.
Premier jour,
lumière,
quatrième jour,
luminaire
et astre.
Deuxième jour,
on a la séparation
des eaux,
donc les eaux
et l'atmosphère.
cinquième jour,
poissons et oiseaux.
Troisième jour,
la portion sèche
et tous les mondes
végétales
avec des arbres
mûrs déjà
avec leurs fruits
et tous les animaux
terrestres.
Au sixième jour,
en faisant une pause
pour donner
l'importance
qui a dû
à la création
de l'être humain,
en faisant l'homme
son image
et sa rassemblance.
Tous déjà prêts,
tous déjà parfaits,
tous déjà mûrs
et parfaitement fonctionnels.
C'est l'un des arguments
cosmologiques
qui sont présentés.
C'est cet aspect
de la nécessité
de cette intégration
mutuelle
pour que tout puisse
continuer d'exister.
La relation
entre les environnements
et les êtres
qui habitent,
même pour donner suite
à la continuité
salutaire
de l'environnement
et l'interaction
entre les êtres créés.
Donc,
tout devrait être créé
dans une période courte
pour que tout puisse
accomplir
la fonction
de son existence
et tout a été créé
de manière parfaitement
fonctionnelle
dès le départ.
Cinquième aspect
qu'il faut remarquer,
c'est que tout a été créé
de manière classifiée.
c'est-à-dire
Dieu a présenté
quelle était
la classification
et quelle était
la fonction.
Voilà pourquoi
à chaque jour
qui comprend
des êtres vivants,
nous sommes devant
la définition
selon leur espèce.
D'ailleurs,
quand on pense
à l'âge de l'Alliance,
des fois,
on pense que nous
devrions avoir
la représentation
de toutes les variétés
de chaque espèce.
ça,
ce n'est pas nécessaire.
Nous n'avons que besoin
des couples
de chaque espèce.
Les variations,
ce qu'on appelle
les mutations,
les petites mutations
qui donnent
la variété des espèces
suffisent déjà
pour qu'après les déluges,
on ait la variété nécessaire.
Par exemple,
on n'a pas besoin
d'avoir toutes les races
des chiens
dans l'arche.
On a tout simplement
besoin d'avoir
un couple
de chaque espèce
pour donner la suite.
Et donc là,
on voit de manière
très claire,
tout a été créé
selon son espèce
depuis les arbres,
depuis les végétaux.
Qu'est-ce qui concerne
tous les reptiles,
tous les poissons,
tous les oiseaux ?
À chaque fois,
la Bible est très claire
et inflexible.
On n'a pas
les possibilités
par un principe
d'interprétation biblique
de considérer
une transition
d'une espèce
à l'autre.
Vous allez remarquer,
pour chaque jour
où les êtres vivants
sont créés,
nous allons retrouver
selon leur espèce,
selon son espèce.
Ça ne va pas être
un nombre énorme
de fois,
et y compris
lorsqu'il,
dans les sixièmes jours,
Dieu crée
tous les animaux
qui occupent la terre,
ce flètrement.
Et lui,
il sera créé
plutôt
d'une autre espèce.
Il est classifié
comme
humain,
la race humaine
est composée
par hommes
et femmes,
mais on n'a pas été créé
tout simplement
selon notre propre espèce,
c'est-à-dire
être créé,
matière tout simplement
de ce monde.
On a été créé
à l'image
de Dieu.
Dieu a élevé
la race humaine
à quelque chose
qui sera plutôt
à l'image
de son espèce,
si on peut dire
comme ça,
après lui.
Et donc là,
on voit de manière
très claire
l'impossibilité
que l'homme
soit vu
comme
une évolution.
Il est créé
à son sommet.
Il a eu
de l'involution
dans la race humaine
et dans le monde.
Mais l'être humain,
il a été créé
en tant que gloire
de la création,
image de Dieu.
Et
Dieu a aussi
présenté
une évaluation.
C'est très intéressant
de remarquer
quand un ingénieur
va créer
quelque chose,
il va planifier
avant la création.
Il sait
que pour un ordinateur
par exemple
fonctionné
ou une voiture,
ce n'est pas possible
que juste
quelques systèmes
soient connectés
pour que tout marche.
Il faut que chaque
système soit en train
de fonctionner
et qu'il fonctionne
par l'interaction
entre tous ces systèmes.
Et après avoir
fait une œuvre,
c'est à l'homme,
ça devrait être
à nous tous
d'apprendre
à tout planifier,
à tout bien faire
et évaluer
ce qu'on a fait.
Et Dieu,
lorsqu'il fait
l'évaluation,
il va déclarer
des constats
à chaque étape
pour tous les jours
sauf les douzièmes
si ils ne sont pas.
Mais à chaque étape,
il va manifester
et cela
était bon.
Il a vu
que cela
était bon.
et après avoir
créé
l'être humain,
il va dire
quelque chose
de différent,
il va dire
et tout
était très bon.
Ce qui va mettre
plus en évidence
encore
l'aspect
spécial
de l'homme,
mais ce qui va
mettre aussi
en évidence
le fait
que l'ensemble
de la création
qui a fini
au sixième jour
était parfaite
et parfaitement
fonctionné.
donc j'espère
qu'à ce point-là
ce soit clair
pour vous
que c'est impossible
de chercher
à accorder
la description
biblique
à propos
de la création
non seulement
par l'évidence
littérale
mais aussi
par la signification
de ce que Dieu
vise à communiquer.
Il veut
qu'on sache
que l'homme
a été créé
comme quelque chose
d'important
au sein de la création
parfaitement fonctionnel
dès le départ.
La dernière chose
qu'il faut remarquer
c'est que cette
création
elle va décrire
non seulement
la fonction
générale
de chaque
environnement
créé par Dieu
dans chaque jour
ou de chaque être
créé
qui vont agir
selon les fonctions
que Dieu
les a créées.
On n'a pas
de manière exhaustive
la révélation
de toutes les fonctions
de chaque élément
mentionné
dans la création
mais nous comprenons
par la Bible
qu'étant
œuvre
des dieux
toutes ces choses
ont la fonction
d'en agissant
selon leur espèce
d'en respectant
les buts
de leur création
contribuer
à la manifestation
de la gloire
des dieux
de manière
à nous communiquer
une sagesse
lorsqu'on observe
le fonctionnement
de toutes les choses
une sagesse
fonctionnelle
pour la vie
dans ces mondes
mais aussi
une sagesse
spirituelle
pour la gloire
des dieux.
Dieu nous a donné
à l'être humain
une fonction
primaire
prioritaire
et glorieuse
déchiffrer
Dieu
dans son intelligence
sa puissance
sa gloire
dans les mondes
reproduire
sa manière
de faire les choses
dans les mondes
donc développer
davantage ces mondes
les porter
à son plan
épanouissement
on n'a pas
le temps
de lire
tous les textes
mais Dieu
a placé l'homme
au sein du jardin
pour les cultiver
à l'image
de la manière
dont Dieu
l'avait cultivé
pour se multiplier
pour cultiver
la terre
développer la terre
faire de la culture
faire de la science
se reproduire
faire les villes
faire de la société
en respectant
ses fonctions
selon son espèce
et dans la compréhension
de l'espèce humaine
homme et femme
nous allons voir
en respectant
sa sexualité
bien sûr
et donc ici
c'est très important
de remarquer
que la Bible
par exemple
l'Epsomme 19
il va dire
les cieux racontent
la gloire des dieux
l'étendue manifeste
les œuvres des séments
les jours en ont se frit
un autre jour
la nuit donne connaissance
à une autre nuit
c'est à dire
par l'observation
de l'univers
on apprend à propos
des dieux
et on apprend à vivre
mieux dans ces mondes
lorsqu'Adam reçoit
sa première mission
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire
de la science
il va classifier
les animaux
il va nommer
et c'est
par l'exercice
de l'organisation
du cosmos
en faisant de la science
qu'il va constater
que tous les animaux
ont ce couple
mais eux
mais lui pardon
il n'a pas encore
une aide
qui lui soit
semblable
il n'avait pas encore
la forme
et c'est intéressant
c'est en exerçant
de la science
en classifiant
les choses
en reconnaissant
l'intelligence
de Dieu
dans l'ordre
que Dieu avait créé
en apprenant
à propos
de la fonction
de chaque animal
de chaque plante
qu'il est entrant
de déchiffrer
la gloire de Dieu
dans cet univers
et donc Dieu
il a fait
les mondes
déchiffrables
c'est ça
qui est intéressant
ces scientifiques
chrétiens
de nos jours
ils vont
ils vont présenter
que non seulement
le monde
ne peut qu'être
connu
dans ses lois
car il a
une origine
intelligente
mais le monde
il a été fait
d'une manière
à être déchiffrable
l'ADN par exemple
parce qu'on se plongera
dans les évidences
de l'ADN
c'est incroyable
de voir comment
la communication
de l'information
intelligente
est quelque chose
d'incroyable
pour la formation
et la reproduction
des êtres
et donc
Dieu a créé
toutes ces choses
avec une fonction
spécifique
et tout est connecté
à la révélation
de sa gloire
et nous les êtres humains
on a la capacité
de déchiffrer
ces choses
car Dieu a créé
toutes les choses
exactement de la manière
dont la Bible
nous les présente
et pour la suite
j'espère qu'on puisse
méditer dans quelques
arguments scientifiques
qui corroborent
la manière biblique
de nous présenter
donc juste pour
résumer
et finir
donc la Bible
elle enseigne
de manière claire
et inflexible
ce qu'on appelle
les créationnismes
fiat
il a tout déclaré
et tout a été créé
c'est un décret
par sa parole
il a tout créé
à partir de rien
la création
a défini
non seulement
les commencements
de l'univers
mais
les commencements
du temps
lui-même
la création
était rapide
et à partir
du rien
en six jours
littéral
et Dieu
était
il a créé
quelque chose
en dehors
de soi-même
toutefois
dépendant de lui
et il a la liberté
d'agir par les lois
qu'il a créées
ou d'intervenir
comme il veut
l'univers
a été créé
par les dieux
triunes
la trinité
c'était un acte
libre
de la part
de Dieu
l'homme
il a été créé
de manière
directe
climatique
et spéciale
toutes les choses
ont été créées
déjà
en parfait fonctionnement
et mature
et l'univers
a été créé
selon les constats
des dieux lui-même
parfait
ou très bon
les buts
qui Dieu a donné
à toute la création
c'est pour sa gloire
et voilà pourquoi
après lui-même
avoir pris plaisir
et septième jour
qu'il a séparé
et sanctifié
pour la contemplation
de sa gloire
nos vies vont
reproduire
ces mêmes motifs
et nous allons
travailler
pour la gloire
des dieux
à l'imitation
et réfléchir
sur notre travail
devant Dieu
être rédévable
réjouir
la création
des dieux
identifier
Dieu de la création
et les jeux
de repos
adorer Dieu
basé sur ce qu'on a pu faire
pour la gloire
de son homme
et par la contemplation
de sa gloire
la création
a été créée
pour la gloire
de Dieu
Amen
nous allons nous arrêter
là aujourd'hui
et on va considérer
l'image des dieux
dans l'homme
la prochaine fois
et on va
on va
la prochaine fois
et on va